Alfonzo obviously this period in your
life affected who you are as a person
how did this period in your life affect
you as an artist well I guess that every
period in your life affects uses as an
artist as any other thing but definitely
after this period of my life I became it
was a period of that I was very kind of
a what's a word well I was very lonely
I had retreated I didn't really have
much many friends and and yes inform a
lot in my life because my refuge was
going to the movies you know my refuge
was seeing him when you were thinking
about this period in your life you have
your memories you have your assumptions
about your memories and then you have
things that you don't know that start to
change your memories when you're
revisiting the spear in your life what
surprised you most about what you didn't
remember as well as you thought you
might have or you didn't know that you
wish you had no what is amazing is is
how one that you access one memory is
opening this door that leads into this
corridor endless corridor with doors and
a niche store is another memory and then
you keep on just opening memories
whatever surprises how it was like a
chain reaction in which just accessing
one memory and more memories start
coming out and then contrasting those
memories with or my sister with Leo
who's the real person who was the
character of Cleo is based upon then he
would inform more or without him you
looking for locations and finding and
saying oh he know that's the tile and
that tile immediately opening like 50
doors you know so it's a a memory is
funny like that and by the way who knows
if those are real memories right we'll
never know right you have you know
you're charged with recreating something
that Alfonso knows very
well and he's very specific in what
those things have to be in terms of
furniture in terms of tile how much of
your job was digging into Alfonso's
memory and how much of it was trying to
find those things in real life so that
they matched his memory well it was a
combination of things first of all he
started with with a lot of descriptions
a lot of chats that'll function and we
had he was telling very specific
specifically certain things that he
remembered how was the house for example
or how was certain Street or what would
the family will do in a certain period
you know like a probably having dinner
or what would they eat and then but that
for me was a great starting point we
basically dig into some real furniture
of the quadrants family we basically it
was all dispersed how you say that like
a furniture diaspora throughout Mexico
right yes so basically we we we took
some of it we recreate some of them but
also we did a historical research we
wanted to be very specific and accurate
about that so that was also another that
also opened that door of my own memory
as well you know I grew up in the same
neighborhood that Alphonso some years
later so so he was a lot of years later
but nah not that many but there but what
but really there was a lot of a big
emotional connection to all of these
things so then we started to look for
the city that we wanted to recreate a
city that we found after we started
scouting and and that that it was lost
so we had to really recreate a lot of
the things that do you see in the screen
building big sets of the main streets
and completing it digitally yes
Gabriela you're not just revisiting
Alfonso's personal history you're
revisiting a part of Mexico's history
and what's happening with the
Institutional Revolutionary Party our
Prix at the time how important was it to
Alfonzo that you're not just getting his
history right but you're getting Mexican
history right and what's happening with
students and protests and massacres at
this at this time in Mexican history
well it was it was very important as Oh
Hani was saying just now about
recreating everything in an
archaeological sort of process that
really was the way we did this we had a
very long pre-production where we spent
a lot of the time doing tons of research
in order to accurately be able to
portray the scenes that you see in the
film and I I'm not Mexican I'm
Venezuelan and I'm much much younger
than the two of them
and so I did not live that time period
in Mexico but through that research we
were all informed of how to accurately
represent those events and also as you
see in the film there's a lot of
political context all around and that
was very present during that time in
Mexico City so on phone so it was
adamant that he wanted that represented
there so in this effort of not only
digging into Alfonso's memories we also
dug into sort of those important Mexico
City moments to capture them in the film
skip I want to ask you about one scene
in particular and that's the scene in
the ocean and the sound design for that
scene I mean this is a film without any
score so there's no score in this film
that your sound design is the score but
I want to ask particular about that
scene because the sound of that scene is
phenomenal could you talk about your
conversation without Fonzo and what your
orders were and how you ended up
fulfilling those orders with the sound
design you came up with well in essence
we had the same charge to try to
recreate a memory and a history which I
happen to be familiar with myself I
think I'm a little older than you maybe
a few days but I had a similar situation
and in my own childhood and the potion
was a big thing in my childhood and so I
kind of I cheated a bit because I rather
than take you in to Alfonso's memories I
had my own and they were luckily they
were similar so Alfonso said from the
very beginning what we want to do is
create a something like we did in
gravity where we want these sounds to be
surreal and super real and go beyond
just what's being represented well of
course what was being represented it was
kept changing but it was it got more and
more ominous and
terrifying and that was our main goal
was to bridge reality and the memory of
that our own personal memory of what
what it's like to drown in the ocean and
what it might be like and then the the
heightened reality of what we're seeing
on film which helps the audience gives
the audience access to what this
situation could be marina one of the
things that Alfonso did on this film is
he shot absolutely in sequence
chronologically and that he protected
the script so that the actors didn't
know what they would be doing till the
day of a particular scene nor the crew
nor the crew so what does that create
for you as an actor when you don't know
what's gonna happen to your character in
a given day and can you think of a scene
where you as a performer are almost in
real time living the life of the
character that you're almost
experiencing it as the cameras are
filming it yes well that's the way we
did it and I think it was really a
really beautiful gift for an actor
because it really helped us to live the
experience as a real-life experience we
would know everyday what would happen to
our characters and we will be
understanding the journey of all the
family day by day and I think this
really helped not to be anticipating
anything not to be pre conceiving and
just like surrender to to the story to
the characters and to the world that was
being there we we really immerse in a
real-life experience Charlie it's uh
there would be no movie that we just saw
without you and I suspect Alfonso has
told you that right
I want to ask you about libo and about
meeting with her and her story and
finding from her what you thought was
important as an actor even though you've
never acted before this film what was
libo telling you and what were you
taking away from your conversations with
her so that you could honor who she was
as an actor - element A to B la vita the
political Konoha antes de pasar con la
película en esta reunion may hablo sobre
su historia a como salió de su comunidad
como a go a la ciudad y cual era la
relación que tenia cana familia y los
problemas por los que otra vez so in
tanto say Konami Cosi todo en su pasado
esto me identify compo Co con ella y
well Eldar me cuenta que es una mujer
con un corazon a norm and univ on that
this is the kilobase the das cuenta e un
principio me proko como si team or they
they know poder represent ariana grande
mujer de nos early stay on or e y
despues las palabras que ya media in
esta platica como frankly sand on me
boys
well okay well me conventionally the
entregar mi corazon in esta película al
igual que ya dado su corazón a su
familia
fortunately I was able to talk to her
before we started shooting the film and
she told me lots of things about her own
story her history like when she left her
own community when she arrived to the
city the relationship she had with the
family the problems she went through
these were economic problems as well as
others and all these she said I
identified with and I also realized the
mirror I saw her how big her heart was
and how kind she was that was immediate
immediately you know and I was worried
not to be able to honor her enough with
my performance but she was very kind and
the worst she told me were the ones that
gave me peace of mind and actually the
ones that convinced me to then go out
there and pour out my own heart in this
film as she poured out her heart with
this family
Alfonso what were you looking for and
why was jeleesa the perfect person
well I was looking for for label the I
was I was looking for well it was the
case for all the actors and there was a
challenge for the casting director it
was they need to find actors that would
be as look-alike as possible to the
original people but also to feel the
same as the original people the same
sensibility and it was months and months
of casting until and then we have armies
of casting crews through the different
states in Mexico particularly the
southern states because labor is from
Oaxaca and in one in one town in in
Oaxacan one be logical that logic
classic logic Oh ay is where we were so
fortunate to meet to meet with elites
and you know when I saw they the video
thing is I was so used to stars
people that look alike but didn't feel
like and there was something immediately
that there was I think had to do with
her smile and and and yeah I mean and I
immediately wanted to meet with her and
we asked her if she could come to Mexico
City when she walked into the into the
place and start talking to her because
we were it was just like weeks before we
start shooting and I was anxious that
was not finding Cleo
I felt in one hand so excited and
relieved that I had found Cleo and then
terrified that which she would say that
she was not interested as she was Alfons
l thank you so much